president Trump is sizing up the New
Year during a working weekend at Camp
David mr. Trump and vice president Mike
Pence are gathering with Republican
congressional leaders to discuss their
legislative agenda for 2018 before
leaving the White House Friday the
president touted gains in the stock
market and claimed his tax cut bill is
going far beyond what anyone thought
possible but the release of a new book
detailing the inner workings of the
Trump White House is serving as the
latest distraction for the
administration Errol Barnett is at the
White House Erol good morning good
morning president Trump is taking all
his power players to Camp David this
weekend vice president Mike Pence
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson defense
secretary Jim mattis and CIA director
Mike Pompeo will all address the
administration's priorities while Senate
Leader Mitch McConnell and House Speaker
Paul Ryan will address plans on the
legislative front we're going to Camp
David we have a lot of things to work on
a lot of things to accomplish president
Trump is hosting a retreat at Camp David
to discuss his 2018 priority we're
making America great again the White
House says among the weekends topics
will be the economy national security
military funding infrastructure and
immigration reform including funding for
a border wall we're cleaning out towns
of those ms-13 gangsters that's why
we're calling on Congress to fund the
border wall which we're getting very
close to CBS News has confirmed the
administration wants Congress to
allocate approximately 18 billion
dollars for funding of a wall on the
southern border and enforcement measures
we will build a great wall along the
southern border
and Mexico will pay for the wall top
Democrat Nancy Pelosi called the 18
billion dollars in funding alarming and
urged party members to speak out since
the Trump administration ended daca the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
program Democratic leaders have been
negotiating additional border security
measures as a way of passing the DREAM
Act a more permanent solution
in a statement Senate Minority Whip dick
Durbin said the border wall demand is
outrageous and makes a government
shutdown more likely adding the White
House was put in quote its entire
wishlist of hardline anti-immigrant
bills on the backs of these young people
before leaving Washington the president
ignored questions about his former chief
strategist Steve Bannon who was quoted
making damaging remarks about mr. Trump
in a new book fire and fury inside the
Trump White House last night on Twitter
the president called the author Michael
wolf a total loser and said his former
ally Bannon begged for his job when he
was fired the president added now sloppy
steve has been dumped like a dog by
almost everyone but in an interview this
morning with the BBC wolf stands by the
content of his book and believes its
revelations could ultimately harm the
Trump presidency the story that I've
told seems to present this presidency in
such a way that it says he can't do this
job the emperor has no clothes and
suddenly everywhere people are going oh
my god it's true he has no clothes
that's the background to the perception
in the understanding that will finally
end this presidency now one cabinet
member not invited to Camp David
Attorney General Jeff Sessions mr. Trump
has openly criticized him and the New
York Times reports mr. Trump sent a
lawyer to dissuade sessions from
accusing himself from the Russia
investigation last year but the
Department of Justice denies that report
Alex Errol Barnett at the White House
thinks arrow